the nice thing with the lovely thing is
that when Alan first started I'm talking
about the late 1980s when I brought down
the Thatcher administration it was no
Alan brought up in fact administration
he was kind of a bad yuppie he used to
be a baddie but now he's really bad I
mean I'm really evil like Satan's nasty
brother because he's joined new labor of
course and it's difficult in to do this
hello viewer its difficulty to view this
cause I don't wanna give away all the
gags of the show but yes Alan lives at
number 9 Downing Street he's big mates
with Tony and he tells Tony what to do
and he makes a large amount of money can
you tell us how that conversion happened
and well I got a long speech but in the
flow well it's really because Alan
thought that the Tory party had got a
bit sort of sad and flabby and he was
then he met Tony Blair and they had the
idea together to start new label with an
enormous amount of stuff in it I can't
because it's much more international as
well Condoleezza Rice is in it and she's
very sexy actually when you're doing
SATA does the target really have to be
people in power I think it's very good
question yes is the short answer
but I think it's that there's a when I
did the young ones a long time ago as 26
years ago now I think was Mead said no
that's enough we stop now always stop at
the top I met bitter Richard and he
taught me about being on stage we had a
chat and he says always stop at the top
and he didn't stop it at all
well my know me to get when you get with
a live show when she stop you get off
but anyway I'm quite proud that I said
no to the young ones let's stop it there
because while it's going good um and I
promised myself I never ever repeat the
character so we don't do their qug n or
Kevin Derby again or rich from The Young
Ones again once you've stopped it but
perhaps it's because Alan is a permanent
nastiness and it it's written by two
other guys and now Alan is a no I'm
nearly 50 now you won't believe it but
um so Alan is now really really nasty
and so I think it's not a bad idea
to repeat him have you become a bit of a
pinup for politicians the other day was
really great I was we were
look at our new theater which is the
Trafalgar studios been waiting a long
time to get the show into the West End
and won the great actor Alan [ __ ]
just finished with bent at the Trafalgar
studios which used to be the Whitehall
Theatre which is in Whitehall which is
fantastic I mean we're talking like 200
yards from desks where the Whitehall
forces with them that's correct yes it
used to be the Whitehall theta because
call the Traverse studios now and we had
a look around there and then we went for
the walk see Downing Street little piece
of goes right we can't wait yeah all
right
and then we went to to Downing Street to
there has a commons we watched them and
I'm telling you the truth there's a
couple of MPs I kind of hid away but
there we go oh yes right now
that's right now that's pretty bloody do
you think that game there's rip metal
though gamers out of Bastad yeah well it
could be yes do you feel that making fun
of new labour now is really flogging a
dead horse
well if Tony Blair stops being Prime
Minister before the end of July then my
show is going to be a bit knackered was
written by Marx and Graham - the
greatest comedy writers in the country
and they've got two or three backup
scripts so that if the singing postman
becomes the Prime Minister and right if
Gordy becomes Prime Minister they were
all right because some backup scripts
but when do you you're a proper
journalist Adam when the you think
utterly of era I think you'd probably
make it at the beginning of July I
wouldn't run to the end of July
many people calls know you is a
television actor how does it compare
with doing a play on the stage they're
all different mediums I don't know I
mean I've always loved I think I've
always loved a live audience really in
you always loved film don't you because
you wake up in the middle of the other
part of the world and there's lots of
real nice people being around these real
nice to you and you get four billion
pounds for going hello that's the shot
and the next day you might say how are
you know where do two hours of good
full-on stuff in front of an audience my
minion aid I mean bottom and the young
ones came intervie and The Statesman
the New Statesman they were all in front
of live audiences but looking back at
the young ones
the characters were extreme but they
were still recognizable people whereas
today with Little Britain
and League of Gentlemen they're pretty
grotesque I don't know my daddy and me
used to sit down in the sixties
listening to Spike Milligan listening to
the goons and we were falling about the
place laughing at Eccles and and
everybody
Henry Crum hmm Neddy Siegen no less than
that yeah and I said that's what made me
laugh in in that particular way comedy
is dangerous thing that comedy is about
sort of about happiness about being
young you know when you're young my kids
their kids all the mates they're always
rolling around laughing because they
haven't got to worry in the world and
when you're older to keep on laughing
like that is maybe it's very more
difficult as your legs start to not work
and your memory certainly my new memory
starts to not work and other bits of
your equipment and for some people don't
seem to work so if you can keep
attacking yourself a laugh with that
it's a sorry oh I've got a big gay
following well you obviously seem to be
totally back to health after your
accident yep and someone said to me the
other day I said well the thing about
you is Rick I mean every single piece in
your brain has been severely damaged
except your ego which I think was
another other nice thing to say
now I'm perfectly all right I've still
got my quad bike I don't know why that
happened actually why did God want that
to happen when I went up to heaven and
that god I never knew this when I was
dead for five days you know I was dead
for five days and Jesus was only dead
for three this was a 2,000 years after
Jesus was nailed up and and I went out
and I met God and I met Jesus is nice
guy you asked my autograph Lesley so I
can alter it you know it's like and then
God said it I had to go back to do
something else and I don't know what
kind of been so if I haven't achieved
that by now then I will be dead so I
think probably this is God's intention
especially if Christmas is coming this
is Christmas in London 2008 no what's
the year 2006
then you see this is what God's
intention to play to not just Christians
lord knows all the Muslims all the
atheists and all the every single color
and sexual persuasion of the world are
welcome to see my show all they have to
give is their money
I'm sure they'll flock thank you very
much in the flock
thank you man Rick we were